hey Kelly this is Matt I'm excited be
part of your home not alone campaign
we're sitting here in my
state-of-the-art salon that I set up for
my grandmother two weeks ago I did a
video me setting up a spa day for her
she goes to the beauty shop once a week
she has for 30 years and goes to the
same lady and she was just kind of
depressed that you know she was at home
and couldn't go since they had closed so
I decided to try out and see if I could
maybe do her hair for my post with the
video it blew up people were commenting
giving me some tips and tricks and just
seemed like it brought him a lot of joy
and happiness unfortunately we're
practicing the social distancing now and
some cases have gone up in our area so
my dad decided that she was just gonna
stay at home and I still continue to
work so it's just a better idea to stay
safe and just distance a little bit it's
been tough but I'm gonna head over my
parents house and see if we can't do an
interview through the window and see
what she has to say what to think about
when I did your hair I think you made me
look you know yes you you are a good
hairdresser
thank you you think I have another
career well
don't push it how you feeling about this
whole quarantine thing I think it sucks
yeah I miss it is look everything's
gonna get better right it's gonna take
time but it's gonna get better and
they'll all gonna be fine so they say
this they will and be good and behave I
love y'all
[Music]
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my Channel please don't
make me keep going